T
ISSUE.
AN AWESOME SHOW.
GREAT TO SEE YOU AS ALWS.
I'M LAURA INGRAM AND THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" FROM
WASHINGTONONIGHT.
DROZ IS HERE WITH HIS FIRST
TR TO THAT ANGLEINCE HIS RUN
INENNSYLVANIA.
YOU DOT WT TO MISS IT.
AT FIRST, HIGHOPES.
THAT'S THE FUSED OF TONIGHT'S"."
THE DEMOCRS ARE GETTINGDESPERAT.
THEYE RUNNING OUT OF TIM.
THEYEED YOU SCARED.
>> T EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS WE
ARE EXPEENCING WIL IMPACT THE
AXIS THATE HAVE TO FOSSIL
FUELS.
>> M IMPACTS THE CLIMATE
CHANGE BECOMING MORE EXTREME.>>T
OCK WILL BE.
PANDEMIC OF WAR, HAPPENING MORE.
>> Laura: HE'S A WEATHER
EXPERT.
HE HANDLED T TRANSPORTATION
THING SO WELL.
HERE'S THE RE OF THUMB, IF
IT'S SUPER HOT O, IT'S CLIMATE
CHANGE.
IF IT'S SUR COLD AND THOUGH
WINTER, IT' CLIMATE CHANGE.
WHENEVER A CHANGE IS HAPPENING,
IT MEANS YOU HAVE TO RUN OUT AND
GETN ELECTRIC CAR.
ALL RIT, FOR ALL THEIR
FEARMONGERING, THE GLOBALISTS
ARE WORED THAT THEIR DREAM O
RBON NEUTRAL WORLD IS FADINGAWA.
IN THE PAST WEEK, A GIANT
CLATE SPENDING BILL WT DOWN
IN CAPITOLILL.
GERMY GOING BAC TOALL IT
TURNS OUT
COURSE, AMERICANS ARE SEIZI
ABOUT GAS PRICE.
>> IT'S GOING UP, GOING UP, BUT
THE YCHECK'S NOT GOING OUT.
>> I CANCED THE LONG TRI I
WAS THINKG OF MAKING THE
SEASON BAUSE OF GAS PRICES.
>> YOU EAT OR BUY GAS.
IT SHOULDN'T BE LI THAT IN
AMERICA.
>> Lra: DEMOCRATS ARE
BLAMIN REPUBLICA, BLAMINGJOE MAE
VLADIMIR PUTIN
THEY KNOW THE CLIMATE WINDOW IS
CLOSING, SO THEY SEND  THEIR
DRONE.
>> NO ONE COUNTRYAN SOLVE THE
PRLEM BY ITSELF.
WE ALL HAVE T BE ABLE TO REDUCE
TH EMISSIONS AND ACCELATE THETR.
WE ARE BEHIND, WE ARE NOT YET
FULFILLING THE PROMISES THA WE
MADE.
WEAVE OURORK CUT OUT FOR IT.
>> Laura: LET ME TRSLATE
THIS.
WHENOHN HEINZ KERRY TKS
ABOUT AELERATING THE
TRANSITI, WHAT HE MEANS ISHE
TRANTION FROM WHEN Y HAD
EXTRA MONEY IN YOUR POCT TO A
TIME WHERE YOU HAV NONE.
FROM AMERICAN PROSRITY TO
AMERICAN POVERTY.
THE WHITE USEELIEVES THAT
YOU SHOULD BE HAPPY TO MAKE T
SACRIFICE.
>> WHAT YOU S TO THE FAMILIES
O SAY WE CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY$4..
>> THE FUTURE OF THEORLD ORDER
AND  HAVE TO STAY FIRM.
>> Lau: LIBERAL WORLD ORDER?
YOU NOCE HOW THEY NEVER
DENED WHAT IT AUALLY MEANS?
DID BIDEN EVER  CAMPAN ON
LIBERAL WORLD ORDER?
ASAR A I CAN TELL, IT STANDS
FOR ABORTION, ANTI-AMERICANM
ELIMINATING ENEY INDEPENDENCE
TO HELP ME WTHY COURIES.
BU A FEW YEARS AGO, 2018 OR'19,,
NEW WAR NO INFLAON, AND
BLUE-COLLAR WAGER WERE
BENNING TO RE.
OF COURSE, THAT MADE THE LEFT
ABSOLUTELY MISERABLE.
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS WERE HAPPIEST
WHEN YOU WER LOCKED IN YOURHOMET
FAUCI PRESS CFERENCE,
TEIFIED OF A VIRUS WITH ABOUT
A 99.97% SURVIVABILITYATE FOR
PEOPLE UNDER THE AGE OF 70.
THEY LOVED IT WHEN YOUR
EXPECTATIONS WEREOW.
THEY CALLED ITHE NEW NORMA
THERE WAS NOLCOHOL, DRUG USE,
UDENTS FALLING BEHD, MORE
MENTAL ILLNESS.
BUTHE CLIMATE NUTS, THEY WERE
THRILLED BECAUSE TY HOPED THAT
YOU ARE BEG CONDITIONED TO BE
TISFIED WITH HAVING LESS.
TRAVING LESS.
MAKING LESS MONEY.
BECAUSE WE WERE EPING EACH
OTHER SAFE MAMA AND THE PNET
EANER.
>> FEWER CARS ON THE ROAD TO
COME UP PLANES IN THE SKIES HAVE
HELPED THE PLANET BREAT.
>> YOU'VE GOT THE SMOG ON E
RIGHT,HIS IS TAKING ABOUT A
WEEKGO, MUCH CLEAR SKIES AND
CLEANE SKIES BECAUSE YOU D'T
HAVE QUITE AMUCH POLLUTION.
>> Laura THEY LOVE N
PRODUCTIVITY.
THE SKY ISLEANER.
THE DEMOCRATS IN THE GLOBAL
ALLIES AREACK AT IT.
THE ONOMIC DOWNTURN YOU HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND IS N AN
ACCIDENT.
IT'S IMPENDING RECESSION, IT'S A
SURPRISE.
THIS IS T BIDEN AGENDA WORKIN
AS IT SHOULD.
IF IT WEREN'T, IT WEREN'REALLY
PLAN, JANET YELL WOULD HAVE
BEEN FIRED LONG AGO.
THE WHOLE ECONOMIC TEAM WOULD
HAVE BEEN FIRED.
BUT BIDEN THINKS THEY'RE DOING A
BANG-UP JOB.
WE MAY NOT HAVE FORMAL LOCKDOWNS
IN PLACE, BUT AMERICA ARE
STAYING PUT BAUSE OF HIGH GAS
PRICES.
65% ARE SPENDING LS ON GOING
OUT.
61ARE DRIVING LESS TO DO
RANDS.
4 OUT OF 10RE USING SAVINGS TO
PAYOR A DAY-TO-DAYXPENSES.
SAME NUMBER BY THE WAY ARE
SPENDING LESS ON GRORIES.
I'VE GOTO TELL YOU, THATAKES
E SUPER RICHHO ARE DRIVING
THIS INSANCLIMATE LIVE
ECSTATIC.
THELOBALISTS AT THE
ITE HOUSE AND CONGRESS, THE
WORLD ECOMIC FORUM DECIDED
TH TO MAINTAIN THEIR OWN POWERIE
PLET, THEY PROBABLY WANT TO DO
TH, TOO, THEMUST LOWER THE
STANRD OF LIVING FOR THE
AVERAGE ERICAN.
S AIM IS HAPPENINGLSEWHERE
AND THAT'S WHY T DUTCH ARE
WIPING OUT THEIR FARMERS.
BY THE WAY, T STAINABILITY
AGEN INCLUDES K ELEMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE TOORCE ON
WEERN NATIONS BUT ESPIALLY
IN AMERICA.
IT REQRES TAKING AGRICULTURAL
LAND OUT O PRODUCTION, REDUCING
AUTOMOBILE TRAFFIC, ATTACKINGTHD
KEEPINGUEL COSTS HIGH,
REDUCING MANUFACTURING, AND
KEEPING THE CMATE CHANGE
PROPAGANDA IN SCHOOLS, AMERI,
CARTOO, ALL OF IT.
AT THE HOUSEY THE WAY IS
EPPED ON HOW LONG THE PAIN
WILL GO ON FOR AMERINS.
>> THIS IS THE STEP WE ARE
KING TO INFLICT FURTHERAIN.
BUT THE WILL BE CTS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> PAYING THE PREMIUM?
>> LONG AS I CAKES T MIC
TAS AND IF RSIA
CAN'T DEFEAT UKRNE.
>> Lra: AS LONG AS IT TAKES.
DEMOCRATS THOUGHT THEY COULD
CONVINCE YOU TOOLUNTARILY
ACCEPT A LOWER STAARD OF
LIVING FOR YOUR FAMILIES, YOURK.
MANY DEMOCRATS ARE ALREADYN
BOARD TH THAT AGENDA.LIBERALS IE
HILL ARE NOT TURNING ON BIDEN
BECAUSTHEY DISAGREE WITH H
POLICIES.
THEY ARE TURNI ON BID
BECAUS HE'S SUCH A LAME
MESSENGER.
MORE ON TT BY THE WAY LAT ON
IN THE SHOW.
BUTHEY RAN INT A NEW
PHENOMENON THAT THEY HAD NOT
PREPARED FOR, ANTICIPAT.
I'M TALKING ABOUT W IMMIGRANTS
WHO CAME FOR A BETTER LIFE ANDNW
STANDARD OF LIVING.IT TURNS OUTS
AMERICANS STILLANT TO LE IN
THE SUBURBS, HAVE TWO CARS, GOOD
SCHOOLS AT ARE NOT PROPAGANDA
24/7.
THESE SE PEOPLE A NOT
SLAVISHLYOURING OVER THE
ACADEMICS WHO ARE SPEAKING OUT
"THEEW YORK TIMES" LIKE HERMAN
DALY WHO IS NOW URGG AMERICA
TO RETHINK ITS OBSESSION WIT
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
I READ THIS OVER THE WEEKE.
UNBELIEVABLE.
HE SAI IT'S FALSE ASSUMPTION
TO SAY THAT GWTH IS INCREASING
THE STDARD OF LIVING IN T
PRESENT WORLD BECAUSE  MEASURE
GROWTH AND GROWTH OFDP.
IF IT GOES UP, DOE NOT MEA WE
ARE INCREASING STANDARD
LIVING?
WE SAID I DOES, BUTE LEFT OUTAL.
WE DON'T KW THAT THE STANDARDS
IS GOING UP.
CHEMICAL POLLUTION, WILDFIRE,
THE OTHER COSTS IUCED BY
EXCEIVE GROWTH IS NOT CLEAR AT
ALL.
, MY GOD.
THEY REALLY ARE DESPERA TRYING
TO TOTALLY UPEND THE AMERICA
DREAM.
THINK ABOUT WHERE AMERICA WOULD
BE IF WE TOOK HERMAN'S ATTITUDE
AT THE MOST POTAL TIME IN OUR
HISTORY.
OUR WORLD WAR II ASSEMBLY LINE
PRODUCING ALL THE WEANS OF
AMERICAN-MADE STE AND THE IRON
THAT WHAD TO WIN T WAR, THE
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION?
THINK  THE AIR POLLUTIONND
COSTS.
WE SHOULD HAVE STAYED WITH
HORSES.
WE WILL NEVELOSE SIGHT OF T
FACT THATHE GREEN AGENDA IS
BEING PUSHED HARDEST BY THOSE
WHOSE LIVES WILL BE AECTED
LEAST BY THE RADICAL
RERUCTURING OF OUR ECOMY.>> YOUT
CHALLENGE AMERICANS HAVE ER
FACED?
>> AOLUTELY.
THE AMOUNT OF CHANGE, NEW IDEAS,
Y GREATER THAN THE PANDEMIC.
IT MEETS THE LEV OF
COOPERATION THAT WILL BEUNPRECE.
>> CLIMATE CHANG WILL KILLIVE
TIMEAS MANY PEOPLE PER YEAR.
THE PIECE OF THE PANDEMIC BY THE
END OF THE CENTURYHICH WILL BE
ACCELERATI WITHOUT A SIMPLE
OL TO STOP THAT RIGHT AY.
>> Lra: KEEP YOUR EYE ONHIM.
AS WE'VE BEE TELLING YOU FORMONE
ENABLERS HE GIVEN UP ON
AMERICANS.
IN THEIRIND, WE DESERVE TO BE
PUSHED FOR THE COUNT'S
WICK, RACIST, GREEDY HISTORYBUT.
YOU DOT HAVE TO TA THIS FROM
THE CLIMATE CONTR FREAKS
CAUSE IF YOU BEAT TH IN
NOVEMBER AND AGA INTO THE MIC
IN '4 AND
CHOOSE CONSERVATIVE AMERICA,
THE GERNMENT HAS TO STOP
ANSWERING TO THE BUREAUCRA AND
BILLATES, GEORGE SO